there's been a magnitude 7.5 earthquake
that's just struck off the pacific coast
of mexico no details yet on damage or
casualties i'll bring you more
information as we get it
all right let's bring john holman and he
joins us on the phone from mexico city
john what can you tell us
well i'm actually in the uh central
avenue at the moment of mexico city it's
called paseo de la reformer i'm just
looking at lots and lots of people here
that have come streaming out of their
offices and they're work still wait just
get the all clear that it's good to go
back in uh this is where most of
mexico's or a lot of mexico city
skyscrapers are there's no danger here
um just been looking at protection
seville which is civil protection on
twitter
and they're saying that they haven't
reported any damage yet but it will be a
while for the helicopters to get down to
not just in mexico city but in the state
of where this happened which is
mitsurikan in the southwest of the
country and really assess uh what damage
there might be on the ground it is a
strong earthquake over seven on the
richter scale as you said but the most
bizarre thing about all of this and what
people already starting to talk about
here is this is the exact same day the
19th september that mexico had strong
earthquakes both in 2017 and in 1985 uh
that really wreaked havoc uh here in the
capital and people are talking about how
bizarre it is that on the anniversary
the same exact thing that's happened and
it's actually happening the same way we
had a um
a simulation of an earthquake the the
alarms went off uh just an hour ago to
um to mark um uh to mark that
anniversary and then an hour later um
everyone realized that they were going
again it was the real thing but at the
moment so far uh no damage to report
here
all right let's hope it stays like that
thanks so much john holman